retour en france 5e semaine d'audience
au procès des attentats du 13 novembre à
partir d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 26
octobre vont venir s'exprimer à la barre
les rescapés et les proches de victimes
du bataclan on retrouve tout de suite en
direct de la cour d'assises spéciale de
paris notre reporter katia technique
et katia plusieurs témoignages cet après
midi des témoignages poignants
et oui en effet puisqu'il s'agit de
victimes qui se trouvaient à l'intérieur
du bataclan et des victimes qui sont
brisées extrêmement ému quand elle
s'exprime elle souffre aujourd'hui de
divers symptômes qui sont liées à ces
traumatismes et elle déclare décrivent
des scènes de panique tout le monde qui
se place au sol qui fait le mort et puis
il découvre progressivement des
personnes défigurées le sang qui coule
des amis qui agonise donc vraiment un
panorama d'horreur absolue on était face
contre terre distille sans savoir si on
allait se prendre une balle ou pas ce
fut pour certains deux heures d'une
attente interminable des terroristes ce
soir-là tuer toutes les personnes qui
faisait un bruit ou alors dont le
téléphone sonner et puis il ya également
des personnes qui ont réussi à
s'échapper alors lorsque les terroristes
ont rechargé soit ils ont réussi à
trouver une issue de secours soit ils se
sont enfuis donc je lui ai raconté
qu'elle est partie dans une loge qu'elle
a entraînées 50 personnes à sa suite et
qu'ensuite ils ont fait un trou dans le
faux plafond ils se sont réfugiés dans
son plafond ils ont resté trois heures
donc évidemment un témoignage encore une
fois très poignant on imagine l'émotion
de ces personnes et la terreur de cette
personne cachée durant trois heures mais
bien sûr les survivants se sentent
coupables d'être encore en vie il y a
pour certains des séquelles physiques et
pour tous des séquelles psychologiques
très importante avec des arrêts maladie
des insomnies de l'hyper vigilance des
crises de panique en toi vrai choc post
traumatique
ils disent tous ne plus être les mêmes
personnes qu'avant ses revenus dans
toutes les bouches et puis ils posent
des questions ils s'adressent aux
accusés pourquoi ont-ils fait ça je me
demande comment ils ont pu tuer des gens
des questions qui entourent toutes les
victimes dans ce procès